people asked me David how old are you
really it's hard to answer as I've been
on the air a long time also the David
Pakman show has tried many different
formats over the years I thought it
would be funny today to look back at
some of those old shows this clip is the
opening of our show in 1962
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
next up is one of the earliest Clips I
have from my stint as a newsman in the
1950s
the price of gas has jumped to 22 cents
another polio outbreak has been reported
today we're looking back at some of our
earlier shows and to see how the show
has changed over time here are some more
clips of previous David Pakman shows
it's the summer of love and welcome to
David's groovy show east to the world
it's groovy to see all the boss chicks
in that new fashion the miniskirt I dig
it
rumors fly is Paul dead is Sergeant
Pepper a real person thanks to all our
guests and now it's time to get down and
dance
[Music]
boogita
[Music]
that was tonight's top ten videos here
on music solid-gold top video hits of
the week
and on chips
[Music]
that was fun looking back and I admit it
does seem suspicious that I've looked
exactly the same for over 100 years even
more perplexing for genealogy fans is
the following clip unearthed just today
[Music]
reports of more children going missing
in the lava pits have been reported this
is David Pakman signing off for today
and remember don't feed the dinosaurs
[Music]
thanks again for watching and don't
forget to visit us at david packing.com
and sign up as a member
[Music]